in this video you're going to learn how
to find the area of a segment
in a circle so what exactly is the area
of a segment in a circle
well see when we think of a segment
we're usually thinking of a line segment
right
but what it is is this little kind of
half moon shape right here that i've
shaded in so what you have is you have a
sector
which is basically like a pie slice you
know like a slice of pie
but then what you're doing is you're
subtracting off this triangle here
and you're left with just this area of
this like i said like a moon shape
so in order to find the area of this
segment here what we have to do is we
have to use a couple different formulas
we have to find the area of the sector
okay that's the pi slice that i
mentioned right here and then we have to
subtract off the
triangle so that we're left with this
remaining half moon
quantity here which is we refer to as a
segment and in this first example i'm
going to do it using the
formula one half a b sine c and what
this refers to it's just the area of a
triangle but you're taking
the side times the side
times the sine of the included angle the
angle in between those two sides
times one half and that's a quick way of
getting the area of that triangle
so let's do that method first so in this
particular example we have a central
angle of 150 degrees
so to find the area of this sector we're
going to say
150 divided by 360
times pi r squared in this case the
radius is 4.
now if you notice the pi r squared
that's the area of the whole circle
theta divided by 360 or in this case 150
divided by 360 is the
fraction of the whole circle so for
example if we were to reduce this down
by dividing by
10 and if we divide by 3 top and bottom
that gives us
5 12. so this really represents 5 12
of the area of the whole circle 16 pi
so let's go ahead and simplify that down
a little bit further
and i'm just going to use 3.14 for pi or
i'm just going to use the pi key so
we're going to say
5 times pi times 4 squared which is 16
divided by 12
is going to come out to 20.94 i'm just
rounding a little bit here
so 20.94 is the area of our sector
minus now the area of our triangle we're
going to use this formula here
one half now a you see is four
b here is also four since the radius is
always four
so we have one half four times four
times the sine of the included angle
which is 150 degrees
when you're doing this make sure you're
in the degree mode on your calculator so
let's see one half
times 4 times 4 which is 16 times the
sine of 150
it comes out to 4. so you can see 20.94
minus 4
is 16.94
inches squared that's the area of the
segment
now you're saying mario what about
what's the second method well the second
method
is what you can do to find the area of
this triangle
is you can drop a perpendicular like so
okay now see how this is an isosceles
triangle
so what's going to happen here is this
is a 150 degrees we're actually
bisecting that angle so it's going to be
75 degrees
75 degrees and then what you can do is
you can do some trigonometry okay sine
and cosine
and you can find out what's the height
of this triangle which is right here
what's this length here and you can
double it to get the base and then you
can do one half base times height to
find the area of that triangle so you
want to see that part okay so i'll show
you that part
so i'm just going to call this piece
right here h okay
so let's draw that triangle a little bit
bigger so we can see it so it looks
something like this so
this is going to be h and this i'm going
to call this just
x so we have 75 degrees the hypotenuse
here is
4 and what trig function ties together
adjacent and hypotenuse
that's cosine so we have the cosine of
75 degrees
is equal to h over 4 and what trig
function
ties together opposite in hypotenuse
that's the sine so we have sine of 75
degrees
equals x over 4. and now if i just
multiply both sides by
4 that gives us h and if i multiply here
both sides by 4 that gives us
x so let me go ahead and do that on the
calculator we've got 4 cosine 75
which is about 1.035
okay going around too much too early and
we've got 4 times the sine of 75
which is 3.864
and that's x now the thing is see how we
got 3.864 here
this piece here is also 3.864 so we have
to add those together or multiply by 2.
so that comes out to about 7.727 okay
so now the area of our triangle we know
the old way of finding the area of a
triangle one-half base times height
we've grown up with that
the base here is going to be 7.727
the height we said was going to be 1.035
and if we multiply all that together
just make sure we're coming out to four
okay i'm rounding a little bit here and
you can see that's the same area we got
when we use the one half a b
sine c but the whole key here is it's
kind of like a two part
a problem you want to find the area of
sector minus area of the triangle
equals the area of the segment if you
want to see another example in another
video that i did talking about
this concept here about finding the area
of a segment follow me over that video
right there
and i'll see you in that video